now our Chelsea of announced that their
former midfielder Frank Lampard will be
returning to the club as manager the
former England midfielder spent 13 years
at the club where he won 11 major
trophies and is still Chelsea's all-time
record goalscorer one man who knows him
well and knows his potential perhaps as
a manager is his uncle and former
England manager Harry Redknapp Harry
thanks very much indeed for joining me
man Harris I was saying you know Frank
Lampard better than most euros uncle
after all is he right to take the job so
early in his managerial career I think
so Marc you I mean these opportunities
don't come along every every so you know
every day so when the opportunity comes
to magic club like Chelsea you've got to
grab it with both hands and listen he's
radio I've got no doubts about that you
know if you look at people like you know
we've got a pep guardiola was a
magnificent manager you know he great
player at Barcelona legend they're
coming back and end up managing the club
very you know work with the kids were a
little bit end up as manager of
Barcelona so listen he's he understands
the game he's got that we've got a real
touch of class about him as a person
everybody who's ever come in contact
with him or work with him or coached him
or managed him he's been the best
trainer that you've ever seen
no one's worked harder out on the
training ground there Frank has to be a
become a great player so he knows he
knows what it takes and it's going to be
great I think for the young players at
Chelsea that then they're gonna see an
opportunity to finally play in the first
team they've got a great Academy and but
unfortunately not too many kids tend to
come through from that Academy I think
now with the embargo as well Frank will
give them kids a chance but he'll be
taking on the likes of clop and
Guardiola who mentioned I mean this is
big league stuff and he's been a manager
Harry for what a year or so
yeah as I say Yaffe peppered with
straighten almost to Barcelona so it's
not a problem it's no magic for mark
honestly we'll get carried away about
geniuses and technicians and everything
else he understands the game you don't
play all the years he plays he's dad was
a great player 20 years player at left
back for West home it's been brought up
with it game football is his life he
understands what the order is to know
about the game so you know he
understands people he's got a lovely way
with him I don't see it being a problem
the players will look forward to him
coming and managing them and I think the
fans of chills to all the ones that I've
spoke to they're absolutely delighted to
see Frank coming back as their manager
yeah Chelsea's not a club known for
their patience necessarily with managers
who don't win things or even their
patience with managers who do win things
saying that I mean do you worry that it
might be a short tenure they've got to
give him time haven't they no I don't
know oh he needs time of course I mean
it the embargoes on so he's not you know
he finished fourth last year he can't
bring any new players in so if they can
finish I think if they finish fourth
next year they'll be doing very well
that's my honest opinion I look at the
league I see Man City Liverpool
Tottenham I think them free at the
moment you know they're stronger
I've got no doubts this year they'll be
the top three again so Frank 15 fourth
place for Chelsea I think this year will
be a success and if he can win a couple
whatever but he knows it's a tough job
but he will hopefully we'll see some
limb kids that we all keep talking about
who keep going out on loan never playing
finally come back and we're the chill
t-shirt and this could be a new dawn for
Chelsea here the beginning of a you know
new era where young kids coming into the
team getting this chance to play and
show him what they can do and it's great
to have a young English manager
imagine a top six team again I mean it's
a it's something to happen very rarely
and so I'm delighted to see that happen
updates from great young managers about
in this country in the championship and
lower divisions who never get that
opportunity goes so to see Frank doing
it I couldn't be more pleased yeah and
will you be tempted to get on the phone
and help him out Harry hey don't need my
old nerves though I just made
to call from him about five minutes ago
actually and but now I shall be going to
watch some games at Chelsea when I can
you know and get along there and support
him but he's had a great year I mean
there have been a good learning curve at
Derby you had a great relationship with
a chairman Bill Morris who I think it's
been excellent for out this whole thing
he's dealt with it really really
admirably so it's that's been a good
experience is that that one year under
his belt ways worked in the championship
he'll go back into the chills he he will
be is so far and so professional when
everything he does he's a very very
bright guy so he will leave no stones
unturned in managing in Chelsea football
could I believe you me and when you do
speak to him when you do phone him back
after this what will the one bit of
advice you would give him what would the
one thing you would the important thing
you'll say to him well I think he'll be
himself you know he knows that I really
he's not allowed that you know I would
be ringing up and offering too much
advice to because he's a very institute
boy a very clever boy so but you know if
ever he wanted me to to go and watch
apply for him or anything on a Saturday
afternoon I'm a way to available I'd
love to do it but he doesn't need my
help he's got his dad as well he's very
obviously very close to his dead he's
dead follows him you know all over the
country what she needs to put your names
in manage now so now he won't be short
of any any help if he ever needs it but
I don't think he does he'll have good
people around him and he's he's a strong
character I'm sure he's gonna do well
yeah just worry there Harry I mean just
a word about the England women's team
the lionesses I mean what did you make
of that in the in the World Cup
ah fantastic mark I loved it I I focused
and it was amazing it really was good it
was great to watch some of the stuff
they play my god you know it was both
teams America and England you know there
was players there i rung a friend of
mine who manages in lower divisions I
said you want to take a few of these
next year your club you know they were
that it was gee it was fantastic to
watch it really was and it was exciting
and I thought we were so unlucky I mean
the offside girl was inches you know the
penalty miss it could have all gone the
up all being so different but no lots of
positives to take they're not so you
girls will be watching that and thinking
yeah I want to play it was great to
watch and do you think the Premier
League should take them under the wing
and this could be the moment but the
women's game really takes off well I
think I think the Cubs that the clubs
should you know they dates they should
certainly I think it would be a great
idea to see them play on a Sunday maybe
at the claw stadiums you know the clubs
they represent let them play their games
here play you know the pitchers don't do
it the pitches are so fantastic now
you're not going to ruin a football
pitch they look they let other people
other games we have American football
day
so whatever club it is whether it's
Arsenal ladies played it played our
games on a Sunday if the first team are
not playing if they're playing Saturday
plan on a Sunday look let's get them on
to the big stadiums you know and let's
get some crowds earless because it's
it's it deserves that I think yeah and
it does seem as if the crowds are there
Harry just on one serious issue the last
time we spoke we spoke about this
appalling knife crime and you were
helping your friend Mark Prince with the
charity just a catch up on that I mean
how's it going knife crime seems to be
getting worse but I gather you've been
out and about with him a little bit yeah
all marks are fantastic of amazing man I
really is I mean he lost his sons we
know you know - he got stabbed to death
a young young player young fantastic
young man who was going to siphon leave
school and sorry for QPR so Marcus
dedicate his life now to to trying to
help young people to educate and to
educate the going to schools youth clubs
and we look at we look at the set up
some facilities a boxing club football
facilities where the kids can come off
the street and get some focus in their
life and maybe you know get people in to
teach and different skills when they
leave school you know in a workplace so
that's what works mark is working
towards but there's lots of people out
there I met David deanzie of a week that
next chairman of Arsenal who spends his
whole life now going into prisons and
talking to people and trying to help him
rebuild Tate you know he's been around
to something like 90 prison so far David
Dean it's amazing there are people out
there really wanting to do something
about it we have to do something about
it because it's
Gary what's happening on their streets
at the moment yeah and it does seem to
be getting worse well look come Harry
thanks very much just a last question
are you a Boris Johnson or Jeremy Hunt
man yeah for prime minister oh my god
you go and I don't know I'll give I'll
give up to be honest with you you know
it's it's a toss-up and it's it's us up
you know you know I don't understand
about politics mark what Labour say one
thing conserve they never agree on
anything surely they must be saying one
day someone said this is good for the
country and both parties will agree on
it but they never do so in the end I
start to lose a little bit of faith in
politicians